[Music]
in whisper beam news submitted by oh
dude did the [ __ ] is happening
scientists have developed a laser that
can transmit audio messages through the
air the phone so then everyone's gonna
hear it as it passes by what like a
Bluetooth so you're gonna send it to tip
but you're gonna be like told you no no
don't touch into this but I [ __ ] hate
her it's gonna go fine I'm gonna I'm
gonna hear it Oh what is it yeah and
then she's gonna hear it wait isn't that
just fibreglass APM ESPN
isn't that the plow it's not just
bluetooth don't things get sent through
the air anyway isn't that just radio
waves isn't that what happens already
don't we tell them when I text you
it goes all the way up to the sky hit
the [ __ ] satellite and come all the
way back I don't know
no it doesn't it goes into the Wi-Fi
yeah just jumped like a flea on a body
to another body so researchers at MIT
they found a way or they've developed a
way to beam audio messages directly into
someone's ear crazy oh my god that is
next-level creepy I don't want to add
one oh yeah like over in your that's so
cool because like oh I don't want them
to get inside my head but now they can
people are gonna go not in freakiest
that's one of my biggest [ __ ]
nightmares that I'm into my room lights
are all off I'm laying down and then
someone whispers in my ear but I know
that I'm alone that oh dude that
happened to me no oh where when I was
little in Tijuana it was a bruja
stereotypes [ __ ] you guys know like a
love tender love it
my life for some reason I when I would
try to be I would try to go to sleep and
I would hear whispers in my ear like now
that [ __ ] your voice or someone else's
we're not best friends anymore we're not
even friends
no parents talking downstairs and you
heard the vibration of the voice do the
thinking is what I told myself what it
was it was just that my brain was
playing tricks on me and I was just like
it was my mind not letting me go to
sleep but I actually heard it on my hair
so since then till this day you'll never
see me sleep with my ears exposed I
always have to put my hair over my ears
when I go to sleep yeah but sound no I
don't wanna feel like or like just I
felt because when I was little and I
would put the hair over my ear it would
it would it would kind of like make it
go away
ah but then that didn't make you not
hear it right it just muffled it um it
just Maisie it made me feel safer and it
made me feel like I'm trying to think
you had [ __ ] laser ass hearing and
should cover it that means you're
probably blocking the vibration but then
if it's open like this then you could
hear more well so I I do that for two
reasons it's the one is like the that
was what started it was like the
whispering in my ear are you but then
the other one was that I found out that
bugs crawling your ears and [ __ ] so
that's the other well what would they
lower they saying like harder harder
faster puppy kids are gonna hear it the
kids are gonna hear us do it slower do
it slower
what was it was the words I remember I
just remember it was mainly like my my
name being repeated to Bnei Tiffany the
different voices it wasn't like this
name was it your size with me actually
thought about it was it was a tiff or
Tiffany or what do they say did you try
talking back to them no what no because
like I was just telling myself like it's
just my brain trying to freak me out why
are you lying to yourself it's just like
wait
I've run the [ __ ] out of there well you
can't run away from the ghosts in your
head yeah tell me that when I'm scared
doing your head is the same thing like
when you're in the darkness and then
your your eyes play tricks on you and
they make you want to see things I tell
myself like it's just my brain it's just
my brain anyway loop get into it but
then you should have passed yourself how
do they know English how do they know
English is there let me get like why
nots in Spanish you'd be like - defy me
is you're a Spanish name be funny why
it's not her Spanish name it's just how
you pronounce it in Spanish Oh what's
your Spanish name okay mine would be
Quanah is what they would call me what
the M isn't in you know you're thinking
about the ghost [ __ ] right or like brain
Washington [ __ ] but imagine you could
tell each other secrets in the same
[ __ ] room well that's what
that's what I'm saying they're saying
that they're like uses that they might
yo this being used is like for agents
like you know intelligence a job how can
a direct Gossett who's gonna hear it the
laser that so this is the first-ever
laser that isn't harmful to your team or
your eyes but we're several those laser
for Nasir's on cats the good or bad oh
dude have you got that [ __ ] on your eye
Joe Bergner eye on purpose did it one
time in like fifth grade like an idiot
Oh what was that like I couldn't see for
a minute [ __ ] what I do that no I do
that to the Sun no stupid but we would
do it to the Sun so we could sneeze I
did it because I really wanted a work
contact okay that's really dumb really
stupid anyway it's not an interesting
person you know when you chop off your
legs
to be special I wanted braces I wanted
to have pimples I don't know why I don't
know I'm [ __ ] weird right you want
those pretty girls little us to know
what it's like to be normal you like
pimples no one to get pimples now you're
like [ __ ] yes finally I don't say it
don't say it do it you know what that
was it was the ghost happy and you dumb
like to say they don't get them I
recently the Hong Kong trip coming back
those first ever in my entire life I
ever had anything that I could pop and
that was crazy you like it no I hated it
oh yeah I know pours I'm talking about
little Tiffany she was [ __ ] weird oh
my god
so four year old you wanted to go into
puberty no so like 10 year old like
around like between like 9 to about 13 I
was [ __ ] weird
like what kind like eat dirt I think the
thing they want is what we all wanted
glasses I did want glasses oh you do
glasses when you I'm not that worried
that cuz that's the reason why I was
looking in the side looking in the Sun
is the wrong way to go about it why me
that - I just wanted to do it faster
there just wanted glasses and contacts
bastard that's different
I wanna I had all that I had braces
cloths and pimples loser
no [ __ ] you I wanted retainers - I had
crooked teeth that's why when I my teeth
were loose I would wiggle it a lot
because I really wanted them to grow
crooked and they get stuck appropriating
my culture anyway I want to tell you
guys about this blazer you think so this
thing so they're saying that it is
highly targeted
audio signals that by the time it
reaches the receivers ear it's like a
whisper
and so like they can actually hear what
the footage okay what if I'm sending it
to you right and if I'm sending it to
you yeah just happens to walk by and she
blocks it does she hear the secret I
don't know I don't know exactly but they
did say that they tested two methods for
transmitting sound so the first and this
gets really scientific right so it says
first them simply varying the lasers
'la tude through a modulator in a
continuous wave creating vibrations that
could be picked up by a microphone about
eight feet away and the second process
its ditched the modulator and it used a
mirror to sweep the laser back and forth
over the over at the speed of sound and
what's known as dynamic photoacoustic
spectra dropped is about this bit I
can't see it I've been using this [ __ ]
before you stress for that I just set it
right up the [ __ ] secret in the
[ __ ] Shibuya crossing and [ __ ] oh no
yeah yeah so what they're saying is the
thing they're using the water particles
in the air yeah
yeah there's our cool yeah you like the
vibration yeah to create a sound Wow
well what about places with a very low
human they're saying that no matter what
like this laser can do it because if
value in every anyone so if it's around
a person a person always has yeah
moisture because they're using air as a
medium if you can't block it out though
people just blistering me all day and I
want them to shut the [ __ ] up and I
don't want to hear and then how do you
know first if you're crazy or it's just
the laser yeah that's what I yeah what
is my mind friendly existence people
experimenting I think that I think all
the crack kids that live around me when
they're talking to themselves and all
that stuff they're just [ __ ] watching
some show there's secret agents no it's
like they're like you know how like
Wi-Fi signals and all that [ __ ] just go
into our head but then it's affecting
them differently yeah that's right you
ever noticed drugs in their brain
alright stop themselves kids like like
haulers and whatever right they're
talking to themselves kids are talking
to themselves I don't think that's it on
the same frequency yeah never seen a
baby [ __ ] pick up a fake phone a lot
yeah well that's cuz their copy
I see homeless people picking up that
payphone no one on the other end of the
line or maybe they're talking they're
talking to the baby
oh my god full circle hey can you give
me some quick talk of the drug dealer
dude mm-hmm
I never knew I knew I'm gonna take the
phone away from him now yeah I'm talking
here okay imagine using that to cheat on
tests oh my god
that's nothing oh but they're saying
that they could probably use it for um
for advertising too oh I don't want no
sunbae sunbae sunbae this weekend let me
[ __ ] shitty dude yeah don't buy their
site they're saying that you can also
use it to send emergency messages to
individuals and crowds
oh [ __ ] so it is you can't single out a
person yeah that's crazy you know what
I'm gonna bring about intercepting I
don't know how that would I would
personally intercept it
what up can it go through helmets cuz
then we could just have a dome like the
[ __ ] astronaut dome [ __ ] that nobody
[ __ ] with me just like your plug
imagine we got tries to hit on you you
can tell he's like no just wave it away
oh [ __ ] that's time as soon as you see
before it comes to you like a DM now
that song is gonna be real dude baby bad
I did I do I have to whisper yeah
whispers are just reserved for the
people I love what people you thought it
was for to me I feel like [ __ ] what do i
do how to get I got my worst or my first
whisper from Gio
[Music]